[Musik]
[Applaus]
im übermaß ist alles schlecht außer
reisen sagen die spanier wir haben das
mal wörtlich genommen und sind durchs
land gefahren zu bekannten und weniger
bekannten orten auf tuchfühlung mit den
menschen und haben dabei überraschendes
außergewöhnliches und auch viel
emotionales erlebt friedlich sieht er
aus dieser berg der eigentlich keinen
namen hat doch als cumbria berühmt
geworden ist der vulkan der monatelang
feuer asche und lava spuckt ganze
ortschaften vernichtet hat und das leben
auf der insel la palma für viele zur
hölle gemacht hat jetzt schläft er
wieder doch auf der insel ist noch keine
ruhe eingekehrt denn jetzt geht es um
den wiederaufbau
wie hoch sich die lavamassen aufgetürmt
haben wird erst richtig begreifbar wenn
man davor steht alles was ihnen im weg
war wurde mitgerissen
hierunter dem braun schwarzen geröll
liegt die ortschaft zu dunkel und auch
dieser gemischtwarenladen
anders als der rest des städtchens ist
er wieder aufgetaucht an anderer stelle
jessica die besitzerin hat in fast genau
so hergerichtet wie er war
[Musik]
ich wollte ein symbol für jogger
schaffen es gehört zur selben gemeinde
also habe ich ein stück produkte hierher
gebracht
die regale die theke alles ist identisch
nur der fußboden ist anders an den
wänden erinnerungen an den ort der nicht
mehr ist die kirche die schule
es gibt alte kunden die hier herkommen
es gibt aber auch andere die das nicht
tun weil es zu viele erinnerungen gibt
wenn sie hier so viele dinge von
produkten sind aber nach und nach wird
es besser in den vom vulkan betroffenen
gebieten hat das aufräumen begonnen
alles ist in einer dicken schwarzen
ascheschicht versunken jetzt werden die
häuser schaufel für schaufel ausgegraben
sie sehen ja es ist viel viel viel asche
mit schaufeln schubkarren und maschinen
geben wir alle zusammen unser bestes
damit die bewohner schnell wieder in
ihrer häuser können
birgit not und joachim brandt ge haben
ihr haus schon freigeräumt seit knapp
zwei wochen ist der weg dorthin wieder
freigegeben jetzt bereiten sie alles für
ihren un hervor ja jetzt haben wir
endlich 500 liter wasser bekommen in
unseren trinkwasserbehälter aber es muss
ja über die pumpe überhaupt unser haus
in das system gepumpt werden und jetzt
geht die punkte nicht mehr also sie
gingen anfangs und jetzt macht keinen
mucks mehr und so müssen sie das wasser
wohl wieder mit kanistern aus einem
brunnen holen so wie damals als wir sie
das erste mal getroffen haben während
des vulkanausbruchs
sie waren evakuiert weil ihr haus in der
gefahrenzone lage nur sporadisch und mit
einer sondergenehmigung durften sie hin
und den garten gießen und manchmal war
der lange weg umsonst
beide wissen dass sie noch monatelang
inmitten von asche leben müssen trotz
der widrigen umstände überwiegt aber vor
allem alles
also die freude auf jeden fall
wenn ich da andere see wir haben
wesentlich
ganz früh am morgen steigen im hafen von
taste dutzende in ein verbot der
spanischen marine es sind bananen bauern
die auf dem seeweg zu ihren plantagen
gebracht werden die direkte
straßenverbindung ist immer noch von der
lama blockiert
es ist vielmehr der weg ist so viel
kürzer auf diese weise sind wir in 15
minuten auf der farm
viele plantagen sind von der lava
vernichtet worden die die noch stehen
schwer beschädigt durch die asche
ein paar wird man noch retten können
aber der rest muss neu gepflanzt werden
der vulkanausbruch ist vorbei forscher
wollen es jetzt genauer wissen und
machen sich auf den weg zum krater der
boden hier ist noch sehr warm
[Musik]
wenn man direkt am krater ist realisiert
man erst wie dieses gigantische ist es
gibt mehrere nebel krater und man sieht
sehr deutlich die dämpfe die noch
austreten
die spezialisten messen regelmäßig die
konzentration dieser gase kohlen und
schwefeldioxid sie geht zurück immerhin
und alle hoffen dass der vulkan nun für
lange zeit ruhe gibt
was die menschen in ganz spanien
umtreibt und nicht nur dort sind die
enorm gestiegenen energiepreise die sind
so hoch dass die wirtschaft darunter
leidet denn auch unternehmen die viel
strom verbrauchen waren aus
kostengründen ihre produktion herunter
was das konkret heißt erklärt thomas
walde
die reinigung von myra maldonado hatte
gerade begonnen sich von den folgen der
krise zu erholen doch nun gerät sie
erneut unter druck
denn die geräte hier brauchen strom viel
strom und strom ist teuer geworden zu
teuer
vor zwei jahren hatten wir einen
monatlichen umsatz von 6000 euro und
eine stromrechnung von 600 euro in
diesem jahr erlösen wir 3000 euro im
monat und die stromrechnung beträgt 1050
euro das ist ein enormer anstieg und ein
geringer verdienst
von kleinen bis zu großen unternehmen
spürt spaniens wirtschaft die
energiekrise diese fabrik nahe madrid
macht aus steinen zement das ist sehr
energieaufwendig jetzt wird die firma
zerrieben von den kosten für
uns ist das derzeit ein riesiges problem
denn die stromkosten haben sich um 300
prozent erhöht wir haben eine rote linie
überschritten denn unsere
produktionskosten haben unseren
verkaufspreis überschritten so dass wir
eine kritische situation gekommen sind
spanien hatte wenige stromverbindungen
nach mitteleuropa das erhöht die preise
zusätzlich und weil viele verträge hier
flexibel sind schlägt der höhere preis
sofort durch im stahlwerk von 10 bar
sowie steht deswegen heute morgen der
hochofen still zwangsurlaub für 200
beschäftigte mit dieser entscheidung
schreibt die firma versucht sie die nur
den enormen einfluss der hohen
energiepreise zu begrenzen
wenn dieses unternehmen leidet leiden
die zulieferer und andere satelliten
unternehmen die darauf angewiesen sind
und dann geht alles den bach runter
sorge um die arbeitsplätze gibt es auch
bei ferro atlantica das silikon metalle
herstellte und seine produktion wegen
der strompreise herunterfährt
an dem tag an dem wir nicht mehr
rentabel sind schicken sie uns alle nach
hause und das war es wert keine warnung
geben oder so die preisentwicklung
treibt so vor allem beschäftigte in
stromintensiven unternehmen in spanien
um und das sind viele
für manche politiker gehört das auto auf
die liste jener dinge die man am besten
überhaupt nicht mehr benutzen sollte
zumindest in den großen städten madrid
hat angefangen jetzt folgt barcelona mit
einem neuen konzept dass autos nach und
nach aus dem verkehr ziehen soll wir
haben uns dieses projekt einmal
angeschaut
wer schach spielt braucht zeit und ruhe
beides haben sie hier obwohl sie mitten
in barcelona sitzen ein bisschen
weiterspielen kinder eine kleine idylle
bis vor kurzem sah es hier ungefähr so
aus autos lärm gestand barcelonas kurs
gegen verkehrschaos und co2 belastung
ist ebenso radikal wie zukunftsweisend
das ziel ist es ein projekt umzusetzen
in denen das leben im mittelpunkt steht
wenn wir den autos den platz nehmen
gewinnen der gesundheit mehr grünflächen
statt beton heißt mehr gesundheit darum
brauchen wir zonen in denen das auto
nicht mehr der große zampano ist
die straßen von mehreren wohnblocks
werden den fußgängern zurückgegeben der
verkehr außenrum geleitet super blogs
heißt dass hier nur anwohner und
lieferanten dürfen mit dem autor ein im
schritttempo für die die hier leben ein
ganz neues gefühl
es hat sich sehr verändert zum guten ich
kann jetzt mit meiner tochter rausgehen
ohne immer auf die autos achten zu
müssen
sie haben die straßen begrünt und bänke
aufgestellt da können sich die leute ein
weilchen hin setzen das ist schon sehr
gut
vier solcher super blogs gibt es schon
in barcelona weitere sind in
vorbereitung
autos sollen so langfristig aus der
stadt verbannt das öffentliche
verkehrsnetz ausgebaut werden die große
sorge ist allerdings dass die mieten
sprunghaft steigen könnten
es gibt wohnung spekulationen aber unser
handlungsspielraum ist begrenzt wir
hoffen deshalb dass die spanische
regierung einem mietpreis bremse
einführt
barcelona die stadt die als eine der
lautesten und verkehrsbelasteten in
europa gilt will sich neu erfinden und
vorreiter in sachen umwelt sein und
zeigen dass es eigentlich nicht viel
mehr braucht als ein paar pflanzen und
guten willen und das stadtleben
lebenswerter zu machen
können sie sich vorstellen in einer
höhle zu leben in der stadt gar nix tun
dass ziemlich viele da gibt es ein
richtiges höhlen viertel das ende des
mittelalters entstanden ist und dass
immer noch bewohnt wird wir haben uns
dort mal umgeschaut
plötzlich stehen sie da diese seltsamen
hügel wie angefressene termiten haufen
es ist ein bisschen wie im wilden westen
und doch anders und überall wachsen
weiße schornsteine aus der erde das ist
die höhlen stadt von guadix in
andalusien etwa 2500 menschen leben in
diesen grotten da ist zum beispiel
monika bremer eine deutsche architektin
sie ist schon seit 20 jahren begeisterte
höhlenbewohnern im winter ist es
wirklich so richtig kuschelig warm da
drüber und im sommer ist es wirklich so
angenehm kühl dass ich vom klima her und
von der akustik her würde ich die höhle
ungern mit einem haus kaufen
ursprünglich war das eine ziegelei
grotte monika bremer hat sie renoviert
mit natürlichen baustoffen wie früher
sie kämpft für den erhalt der tradition
eine höhle stellt man sich eigentlich
anders vor
wenn man jetzt so eine höhle mit zement
verkürzen wird als würde schimmel würde
kondensation im sommer entstehen und das
passiert in vielen höhlen die auf die
falsche weise behandelt werden das
höhlen viertel von guadix entstand ende
des 15 jahrhunderts damals brauchte die
aufstrebende stadt viele helfende hände
für landwirtschaft und handwerk es gab
aber keine unterkünfte für die arbeiter
deshalb group man höhlen in die leben
wie viele sind bis heute wohnungen
geblieben haben sich einfach nach außen
hin ausgedehnt sogar eine kirche gibt es
für die grotten gemeinde
fahrer manuell am sqs ist gerade dabei
eine taufe vorzubereiten doch statt ins
kirchenschiff zu gehen biegt er in einen
kleinen raum ab es ist die alte kirche
eine höhle
die meisten leute bevorzugen diese höhle
es gibt taufen und hochzeiten gestern
gab es ein begräbnis jubiläum sie wollen
immer dass es hier stattfindet es ist
der ort den alle besonders lieben
und weil auf die vielen menschen nicht
alle in die kleine höhle hinein passen
werden die gottesdienste auch mal per
video nach draußen übertragen
[Musik]
leben in einer höhle heute ist ganz
anders als noch vor etwa 100 jahren hell
war es nur mit offener tür es gab keinen
strom kein fließend wasser
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt in der küche das
wichtigste hier ist der kamin er ist der
ort an dem die familie im winter
zusammen saß der ort an dem gekocht
wurden
maricas schickt uns auf eine zeitreise
in eine typische höhle aus vergangenen
zeiten von der küche sind es nur ein
paar schritte bis zum stall
bis in die 80er jahre hinein war es
üblich bestimmte tiere wie esel und
maultiere oder sogar schweine direkt in
den wohnungen zu halten
nicht alles von früher muss man
übernehmen monika bremer aber weiß
tradition und moderne zu vereinen sie
stellt im hof ihrer höhle bausteine aus
lehm und pflanzen her lernen von den
alten und von der natur
man soll ja viel wasser trinken heißt es
so schön die diesen ratschlag beherzigen
bedienen sich oft nicht am wasserhahn
sondern kaufen mineralwasser und der
bedarf steigt in burka südlich von
granada hat vor kurzem eine neue
abfüllanlage ihrer arbeit aufgenommen
und umgehend proteste ausgelöst viele
einwohner nämlich befürchten dass die
ressource wasser dadurch knapp werden
könnte
eine protestaktion wie ein theaterstück
ein raffgieriger capitalist steht der
erde das wertvolle wasser in den augen
der umweltschützer ist der kapitalist
dieses mineralwasser unternehmen am fuße
der sierra nevada
der klimawandel kommt in zehn jahren
werden wir probleme haben für uns ist es
also unerklärlich dass diese anlage bis
zu 90 jahre lang wasser abholen und
verkaufen kann
5 millionen liter wasser werden pro
monat hier in flaschen abgefüllt doch
dabei wird es nicht bleiben das
unternehmen hat eine lizenz für das
fünffache eine unbedeutende menge nennt
das death
eine stadt wie granada verbrauchte an
einem einzigen tag so viel wasser wie
wir höchstens in einem jahr entnehmen
dürfen die bürger hier brauchen sich
keine sorgen zu machen dass die
ressourcen abnehmen
noch hat die region südlich von granada
genug wasser doch es gibt erste
warnzeichen dass es trockener wird und
für viele anwohner ist die wasseranlage
mit dafür verantwortlich
rosa fernandez führt uns zu diesem
brunnen in den vergangenen jahren lag
der wasserspiegel bei 64 metern jetzt
musst du noch einmal nach
64 meter und es ist trocken total
trocken
erst bei 67 metern trifft das senkblei
auf wasser das
[Applaus]
ist der beweis dass der
grundwasserspiegel sinkt in einem jahr
mehr als zwei meter
mineralwasser ist ein großes geschäft
allein in der provinz granada gibt es
elf apfel anlagen
wir werden weiter investieren und damit
neue arbeitsplätze schaffen und
wohlstand und wir werden mit den bürgern
zusammen arbeiten
wasser ist ein wertvolles gut am fuße
der sierra nevada hat das ringen darum
schon begonnen
die mittelmeerküche hat einen
ausgezeichneten ruf gesund ausgewogen
und nicht dick machen und man könnte
meinen dass auch in spanien nach dieser
tradition gekocht und gegessen wird ist
aber nicht so viele spanier sind
übergewichtig und ernähren sich falsch
der verbraucherminister wollte seinen
landsleuten deshalb eine mittelmeerdiät
verordnen wie das ankam erzählt er denn
jetzt thomas walde es fällt auf wenn man
sich um sind spanien hatte ein pardon
dickes problem das deckt sich mit
wissenschaftlichen daten über die
verbreitung von fettleibigkeit und
diabetes 2 der verbraucherschutzminister
hat darum versucht spanien abzuspecken
in diesem video präsentiert er den
schuldigen
was denkt ihr wenn ich euch sage dass
der exzessive fleischkonsum unserer
individuellen gesundheit schadet und dem
planeten der minister fordert zur
traditionellen mediterranen küche
zurückzukehren tomaten oliven öl
ernährungswissenschaftlern schmeckt das
fleisch ist aus gesundheitlicher sicht
besonders schädlich wenn wir es mit
rotem oder verarbeitetem fleisch zu tun
haben wir sprechen hauptsächlich über
den zusammenhang mit pathologien die
herz kreislauf erkrankung insbesondere
diabetes 2 und darmkrebs das sind die
größten risiken eines wohn
fleischkonsums
auf den märkten spaniens empfinden viele
den vorstoß hingegen als halb gare
fleisch gehöre zu spanien ich bin 68
leben noch und habe mein ganzes leben
fleisch gegessen
es sind auch gewohnheiten dass in
bestimmten gegenden mehr fleisch als
fisch gegessen wird
die botschaft ist zu drastisch und
verteufelt einen ganzen sektor der viele
arbeitsplätze schafft vor allem in der
produktion und den ländlichen gebieten
man ist was man isst oder eben nicht ist
das thema kochte so sehr hoch dass sich
der chef des ministers zu seiner
ernährung äußerte
die finanzmittel über diese polemik kann
ich mich nur mit ganz persönlichen
worten äußern wer mir ein medium
gebratenes steak vorsetzt das ist
unschlagbar ist immer die freiheit und
frischfleisch gehören für spaniens
regierungschef weiter zusammen und für
viele seiner landsleute auch vom
speiseplan nehmen wollen sie nur eines
die debatte darum die stadt um die es
jetzt geht ist berühmt für ihre
architektur
hier ist die renaissance noch
quicklebendig der ort liegt umgeben von
olivenhainen und es gibt eine ganz
besondere töpfer tradition in
smaragdgrün
wir sind in eine kleine stadt in
andalusien und unesco-weltkulturerbe
hier ballen sich förmlich eindrucksvolle
paläste kirchen und herrenhäuser aus der
renaissance erbaut nach italienischem
vorbild als zeichen für einfluss macht
und geld
und so residierten die adelsfamilien
damals durchaus pracht wollen
von nathalie empfängt uns er hat den
palast vor vielen jahren erworben und
restauriert in der bibliothek kostbare
bücher dieses hier ist aus dem jahr 1540
leben fast wie in einem schloss
jeder spanier kennt okada das liegt an
einer redensart wenn jemand vom thema
abschweifen sagt man hier geh nicht
durch die hügel von jupiter der legende
nach ist ein hauptmann kurz vor einer
schlacht in der stadt plötzlich
verschwunden und erst wieder aufgetaucht
als alles vorbei war zur begründung
sagte er er habe sich in den hügeln von
uwe da verirrt
seit urzeiten tradition ist das
kunsthandwerk paco titus stammt aus
einer jahrhundertealten töpfer familie
seit seiner kindheit hat sich viel
verändert
in dieser straße gab es 38 topverein das
war sehr schön jeden tag kamen sie mit
eseln von weit her es gab den
öffentlichen brunnen vor dem immer
wasserträger schlange standen um wasser
zu holen
er stellt seine waren noch nach den
alten regeln her dazu zählt auch das
grün das schon die mauren benutzten als
sie jeder sagen hatten
[Musik]
da teilt sich den weltkulturerbetitel
mit einem anderen ort bei st es ist
sozusagen die schwesterstadt und hier
ist das alte stadttor das noch aus der
zeit der mauren stammt
nach der eroberung durch die christen
1227 entwickelte sich besser zu einem
einflussreichen zentrum auch hier lebt
die renaissance noch weiter
hinter den mauern von barca verbirgt
sich eine kunst die zwar tradition hat
aber neu ist in der stadt gold forden
stickerei manuel lozano widmet seine
fingerspitzen den verzierungen von
gewändern nicht irgendwelche gewänder
für die figuren der osterprozessionen
die karwoche ist denn da es sehr wichtig
sie ist ein kulturgut und ich glaube
dass es hier eine große nachfrage nach
diesem handwerk gibt
und so sieht es aus wenn es fertig ist
goldener glanz
[Musik]
zwei städte ein titel und viel mehr als
nur sandfarbene steigt
er ist spanier sie deutsche er wollte
eigentlich immer rockmusiker werden sie
war immer für klassik jetzt leben beide
zusammen in sevilla und spielen werke
aus dem barock auf ungewöhnlichen
instrumenten und sie haben damit
erstaunlichen erfolg wir haben das
musikerpaar besucht
[Musik]
dieser gesang diese musik verzaubern und
überraschen flamenco gesang zu
barockmusik eine eigenwillige mischung
auch was die instrumente anbelangt
gespielt wird auf kniegeige kampen es
ist die spezialität dieser beiden
musiker er spanier sie deutsche ein
besonderes paar mit einer gemeinsamen
passion alte musik
es war nichts wonach ich gesucht habe es
war etwas das ich auf meinem weg
gefunden habe und den dass ich mich nach
und nach verliebt habe wie die alten
paare die sich erst nach längerer zeit
wirklich lieben lernen
ein sehr vielseitiges instrument und es
gibt sehr viel repertoire für für alte
musik für die ganze familie bei und
johanna rose sind auch privat verbunden
sie leben in sevilla einer stadt die für
viele so etwas wie der mittelpunkt des
universums ist
mein erster ganten lehrer sagte sevilla
ist das epizentrum der welt in dem sich
schönheit und das gute leben
konzentrieren
[Musik]
jeden tag tauchen die beiden im
probenraum ein in die zeit des
sechzehnten und 17ten jahrhunderts
eigentlich wollte familie gitarre
studieren doch die ist jetzt nur noch
ein deko stück
ich höre immer noch rockmusik das macht
mir spaß vielleicht vermisse ich es ein
bisschen schlecht e gitarre zu spielen
oder mehr in die welt des heavy metals
einzutauchen aber fehlen tut es mir
nicht
ein junges paar barockmusik und alte
instrumente das muss kein gegensatz sein
jetzt sollten sie sich ihre wanderschuhe
anziehen wir nehmen sie mit in die berge
auf einen steigt der entlang einer
tiefen schlucht wird und der lange zeit
als der gefährlichste in ganz europa
galt
eine 300 meter hohe felswand und
mittendrin ein schmaler pfad schon
allein der anblick ist schwindelerregend
wir sind unterwegs auf dem camino del
rey dem königsweg einsteig zwischen
himmel und erde in der provinz málaga
sandalen sind hier ungeeignet und auch
ohne helm darf keiner durch die schlucht
ein spaziergang ist es nicht doch der
pfad ist gut gesichert mit stahlseil und
geländer aber immer mit freiem blick
nach unten
ich hatte zuerst ein bisschen angst
davor aber es ist wirklich wunderbar es
lohnt sich es ist super schön ist ein
wahnsinniges gefühl hier entlang zu
laufen herrlich der steig war
ursprünglich kein wunder sondern ein
arbeitsweg für bauarbeiter die von einem
stasi aus einen kanal zur versorgung der
städte errichteten er galt als der
gefährlichste weg europas am stausee
treffen wir pedro kann der weiß was die
männer damals geleistet haben sein
großvater aber einer der arbeiter
ein kanal und ein elektrizitätswerk das
war für den beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts eine herausragende leistung
die stadt málaga bekam zugang zu den
neuen technologien wie strom und
fließend wasser in den häusern
1921 traute sich auch der könig auf die
planken eine besondere würdigung seitdem
heißt der steig königsweg
nach ende der arbeiten aber verfiel der
port nach und nach pedro kann der ist in
unzählige male gegangen es ist sein weg
ich bin genetisch mit dem kamin ito
verbunden ich bin seit meiner kindheit
dort und ich besuche ihn immer noch mit
neugierde es ist etwas persönliches was
mich an den bindet ich habe meine liebe
zum coming to nie verloren
seit ein paar jahren thront ein neuer
pfad über den alten und lockt wanderer
und naturliebhaber an die schlucht ist
eine welt für sich lebensraum auch für
nicht menschen da ja zum beispiel haben
hier ihre nester im weniger ausgesetzten
weg abschnitt steht man mal vor
bergziegen mal fröschen die misstrauisch
die wanderer beugen
[Musik]
es ist beeindruckend aber man fragt sich
manchmal ob der weg auch wirklich stabil
ist denn wenn man den alten weg sieht
und seinen zustand dann sollte der neue
schon richtig sicher sein
sicher ist er aber eben auch wackelig
vor allem am ende der drei kilometer
langen strecke eine hängebrücke über den
abgrund
nicht jeder schafft das ohne
unterstützung doch was bleibt ist das
unbeschreibliche gefühl für kurze zeit
teil einer atemberaubenden kulisse
gewesen zu sein
unsere spanienreise ist hier zu ende es
gibt noch viel mehr zu berichten über
dieses land aber das erzählen wir ihnen
ein anderes mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]